el espacio aéreo de taiwán ha empezado
esta tarde a recuperar la normalidad lo
han dicho fuentes del aeropuerto
internacional de talibán que esperan que
la actividad se haya completa mañana más
de 900 vuelos se habían quedado
afectados y 200 habían sido cancelados
en los últimos cuatro días el regreso
del transporte aéreo es la primera
consecuencia del fin este mediodía de
las maniobras militares chinas las
mayores de la historia en taiwán y que
habían provocado el bloqueo de facto
tanto aéreo como marítimo una veintena
de barcos chinos y taiwaneses se ha
apuntado esta mañana en las cercanías de
la línea media a la frontera marítima
oficiosa los primeros con la intención
de cruzarla los segundos para acortar
sus trayectorias es lo que un analista
militar ha descrito como el juego del
gato y el ratón en el que ambas partes
han mostrado autocontrol y prudencia
para evitar accidentes fatales parecidas
maniobras se han visto en el aire con 20
cazas chinos y 14 taiwaneses estas
maniobras son la respuesta china
nancy pelosi el mayor cargo político
estadounidense que pisa la isla en 25
años ese viaje había sido
muy criticado por china que intentó
evitarlo con promesas de maniobras
militares muy contundentes